hello everyone and welcome to one of the
coolest games you've never seen either
because it hasn't been showcased very
much or because it's simply longer than
30 moves and you'll like short games but
regardless I'm very sure you're gonna
enjoy this one it's it was played in
2009 in bill chess festival between
Alexandre morozova and Maxine for Sheila
Grove
neither of them need any additional
introduction so we're just gonna go
straight into the game and this game was
suggested a lot on this channel so it's
about time I show it as you can see I
username the jola
1 9 9 6 has been suggesting it over the
course of 6 past months so there we have
a jolly I I do hope you enjoyed this
game and like I said I don't know if you
follow my other social media the books
have arrived there we have it
Fisher versus Spassky chess match of the
century by sweat to zergling rich and
also the other one also the 1972 World
Chess Championship Fischer Spassky by a
Larry Evans and Ken Smith so they are
you know a pretty vast vast books so I'm
gonna prepare it for tomorrow but for
today I decided to show this game so
like we said morosely which has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have C 5 it's a game from round 8 so a
pretty important game not that all of
the games aren't important
but you know if you even if you mess up
in the beginning of the tournament you
can make up for it later
and it was a 6 player double round-robin
so not a lot of games left to be played
in in the tournament
Knight to f3 d6 d4 seek at first Knight
captures Knight to f6 and the Knight to
c3 we have a 6 going into the night of
variation and f3 e 6 we have Bishop to
e3
we have b5 by maxime Queen to d2 and now
Knight B to d7 so this is now transposed
into the show meaning in a variation we
have g4 h6 and now a queenside castle by
mo Rosalie's b4 and okay we have Knight
back to e2 and Queen to c7
h4 by Morris preparing g5 and we have d5
Maxime ignores any threats on the
kingside and decides to attack in the
center while keeping his own king is
still in the center Knight to f4 Motors
which ignores the pawn and he prepares a
very nice idea here
but also if you're you know paying
attention also e5 is a very nice move
here by for black and maxime indeed does
play it we have a five on the board and
here Knight F to e6 this was play
planned by Milosevic so what do you do
here it's not really all that possible
to just move the Queen out of the attack
for example Queen to d6 you get a knife
capers on g7 with Czech bunch of
captures and now Knight to f5 attacking
the Queen and the bishop if the Queen
defends the bishop then you get a
captures on d5 and it's just a terrible
mess of a position for black white is
simply much better here
so after this night f2 e6
maxime simply captures the knight we
have F captures on e6 and Dena comes
Knight captures on e6 again with an
attack against Maxim's Queen Queen to a5
they are now with ideas of capturing an
a2 e captures on d5 and Queen captures
on a2 and already this is move 16 Maxime
is threatening Queen to a1 checkmate we
have Queen to d3 motors which makes some
room for his King if Queen to a1 is
plated then the King has a nice escape
route we have King to f7 a very nice
move getting the King away from the
center and now it's White's plan or what
does y do here first the motors which
pushes g5 we have Knight captures on d5
and now you don't capture on d5 back
because if you capture then Queen
captures rook captures and the King
capers on e6 as the knight is no longer
defended by the pawn and now what equal
material on the board
black will be somewhat better so not
really something to look for wood white
here instead motor switch goes Bishop to
h3 a nice developing move simply
defending his knight on e6 we have
Knight captures on e3
and here again a very nice critical
moment in the game where if you capture
on e3 for example Queen captures you get
tonight to c5 and what do you do here
now your knight is under attack and also
you have to you have to decide what to
play here first g6 would have been
played and after King to g8 you have
Knight captures on f8 and now after
Bishop captures on h3 Queen captures on
c5 rook captures on f8 Queen captures on
e5 and here after Queen to e6 Queen
captures Bishop captures you get rook H
to e1 bishop moves and now h5 you have
this position where the where over white
is up upon but black is actually up a
piece but it's not all that it's not
really an impressive piece because black
will pretty much never be able to get
this rook from a trade into the game so
pretty much a very very funny looking
position but ok it wasn't more Rosa
which is plan to capture this Knight
either way so first he plays Knight to
d8 with check and here of course you
don't want to play something like King
to g8 you get Bishop to e6 with check
you can see that the queen is still on a
2 this would be a very unpleasant ending
for black
so after Knight to the 8th check King
the e7 is played and now we have Knight
to c6 with check it seems that this King
to e7 wasn't wasn't perhaps the best
move for black but you know you do have
to play something Knight to c6 would
check we have King back to f7 and now g6
with check King to g8 and now comes
Queen captures on e3 finally capturing
that that night Bush of the c5 now with
an attack on the Queen Queen to e4 here
aligning with the rook but there's
really nothing black can do here white
can always go nice to e7 and capture the
rook if he wants to but white already
sacrificed some material for the attack
so it's not all that recommended to go
after material Knight back to f8 a very
important defensive move for black as it
does keep an eye on the e6 square black
constantly has to keep his Queen on this
diagonal because
you at some point get a move like winter
d5 check it's all over for black here we
have worked to da8 a very nice move
pinning the night and also ideas like
night captures on f8 will be possible in
the future Bush of the b7 here pinning
the night also defending the rockin a8
and here maxime offers a trade of rooks
and this is a move 25 morosa which is
now on the move he has to play his 26th
move and this is the critical moment in
the game pause the video here and try to
find a winning idea here for white so as
usual I'll give you a couple of seconds
to do it it's a very important game
between two grandmasters so you know not
don't need to rush it for those of you
who were able to do it a congratulations
you have found a move that more research
and the most likely Maxima shellgrove
have missed during this game and if you
found rook captures on f8 then you have
found the correct idea and you will win
this game King captors on f8 if you
capture the rook with the king then you
get the Queen to f5 check King has to
move back and now we get Queen captures
on e5 and the thread is of course a
Bishop to e6 we'll check the Queen is
still on a2 and here it doesn't really
matter what you play you can give you
can give a check here after King moves
Queen captures rook on h1 but it doesn't
really matter what move you play still
Queen e6 check is coming King moves and
Queen to f7 checkmate on the other hand
after this rook captures on f8 move if
black decides to capture with the rook
then you get Queen captures on e5
immediately again the threat is Bishop
to e6 winning the Queen
but then after Bishop to c8 countering
the bishop you simply get to the bishop
captures on c8 and again you can't
capture with the rook but there isn't a
better move here for example what
captures Queen captures on c5 and after
Queen to e6 you can simply play Knight
to e7 check King has to move Knight
captures and now whatever happens it's a
discover to check you get a nice Queen
to b6 move you either offer a trade of
Queens and now whatever black plays
loses the game
for example if he captures the knight
then rook to d1 is coming and here there
is no defense against rook to d8 even
though black is up material this rook on
h8 makes it impossible for him to ever
actually prove it
but here after Bishop to b7 morozova did
not find rook captures on f8 rather he
played rook captures on a8
this is probably one of those moves that
he will remember for for the rest of his
career and the rest of his you know life
after perhaps he he stops playing
professional chess but in such an
important tournament like bill chess
festival surely I moved to remember but
okay he played rook captures an eighth
and white is still better here
Bishop captures and now h5 protecting
the pawn on g6 rook to h7 a very nice
defensive resource by Maxime offering a
rook so he can activate his pieces and
also a very important flight Square for
the King so now the Queen can finally
move as if any checks are given on this
diagonal the King can move to h8 okay
rook to e1
there's always time to capture the rook
white is not in a hurry
Bishop captures on c6 Queen captures on
c6 and now push up to d4 threatening to
capture on b2 murasa which goes king - D
- he doesn't allow this check this
capture to come with chick Queen
captures on b2 and the now comes Queen
to c4 with check King to h8 and now King
to d3 Morris which has ideas of bringing
his even his King into the attack
because the Queen is pretty much stuck
here on the Queen side a5 Maxime says
tomorrow's which you have no way of
improving your attack and there's no you
know there's no finishing blow here so
I'm just gonna push my passport we have
Queen to c8 morozova chip threatens
Queen captures on f8 but he misses Mac
seems the next idea
Queen to a3 this comes with check King
to e4 morosely she brings the King into
the center of the board as planned and
now comes b3 a very nice move the queen
is now guarding night from f3 and okc
captures on b3 so what's the idea here
you're the queen is guarding the night
yes but okay you've just given
of your pawns what's what's your plan
here a for this is the plan and it's
very interesting if B captures on a4
then you get this Bishop to c5 move the
bishop joins the defense of the night
here and now the queen can capture an a4
while also giving check to the White
King so for example King captures on e5
now Bishop to e7 let's say Queen to c4
Queen captures on f3 and now black is
still up in material but White has a
king on e5 I think they're really it's a
very interesting position black doesn't
have really any means of punishing the
wife Dingaan e5 you know he can give
some checks and and stuff but there is
no win here for black or for white it's
pretty much a draw position however
funny it sounds but okay after a four we
have rook to be one more rosy which now
idea is that if a pawn captures here
that he's just gonna capture with the
rook and now of course rook Queen
captures here is followed by Queen
captures on f8 Queen to g8 and now Queen
captures King captures G captures on age
17 captures and now f4 of course you
cannot capture because King captures
Bishop but after something like g5 and
after F captures on e5 black can simply
capture here and even though white has
upon and the bishop the bishop is of the
wrong color as the queening square so
it's a it's a drawn endgame so probably
if Maxime wanted to do this he could
have done this but he wants now as
morozova didn't miss his opportunity and
move 26 Maxime wants something more than
a draw Queen to b4 here and okay Queen
to c4 nama-rasa which offers the trade
of Queens but Queen to be seven now
comes with check Maxime declines it
Queen to d5 now Queen to b4 between back
to c4 and now Queen to d2 and here would
a move like would move like Queen the c8
the game probably could have still
continued for example Queen e2 check
King moves now comes Queen to b5 check
King moves and now Bishop to c5 again
black is in time to protect the night on
f8 and now Bishop
f1 is the move to find but you have to
find this Bishop to f1 move if you're
ever going to play the Queen to see it
move that starts this variation and now
of course you don't want to capture
because of Queen captures here but now
after Queen to b6 you get b4 also a very
nice move and now white manages to get
some counter play because Bishop
captures is impossible due to Queen
captures on f8 with check but short
captures rook captures here and now it's
simply all over black still can't get
his rook out of the game and whatever he
plays he's getting checkmated it doesn't
really matter
rook here for example Bishop to c4 is
checkmate so K after Queen to d2 we have
Bishop to g4 morozova doesn't go for the
Queen to see a client here a turkey
plays Bishop to g4 and then out comes a
three Queen to f7 again threatening to
capture the knight now from f7 Queen to
c2
I wouldn't attack on the rook and now
comes King to d5 Queen to c5 check you
can't capture the look of course the
night is still hanging
so first Queen to c5 King goes back and
now while the Queen is guarding the
night on f8 now comes a to attacking the
rook rook moves the c1 and now simply a1
with Queen rook captures Queen and c5
Bishop captures on c5 and now comes
Queen back to d5 and now if you look at
the position black is still a material
but it's still problematic for black to
develop his pieces so how will Maxine go
about it now we have Queen to e1 check
King to d3 and now comes Queen to d1
check King to c4 and now Queen captures
King captures and now comes rush up to
a3
we have Bishop to f5 King to g8 and now
comes King to e5 this King to G it is a
very nice move because it prepares rook
to h8 because if you look at the
position now Maxine has a rock on h7
that he can't get into the game the King
is pretty much stuck here and the Bishop
and pawn are completely blocking the
knife from f8 - from entering the game
so although black is up so much material
he still has to find a way how to get
his pieces
activated King to g8 this is the correct
idea and now capturing the rook is met
with knife captures on h7 and after King
captors knife to f6 and now although
it's still a pretty tricky position to
play for black but because you are up a
night you will still win this game but
after King to g8 King captures on e5 was
played
now comes a rock to h8 the rook is now
saved and after King to d5 92 h7 the
only way to activate your pieces you
have to capture now pawn captures on h7
we have King to have 7 and Bishop to g6
with check King to f6 and now comes f4
Bishop to see one attacking the pawn and
now pawn to f5 and now it's very
interesting although black is up a whole
rook how do you win this game you can't
use any of the points white still has a
passed pawn and you're the only way to
win this is to either somehow try to
still meet your stalemate your opponent
so he has to start pushing his bones
into suicide or you will have to
checkmate the white king so how will
Maxime do it bishop to d2 okay we have
King to d6 now comes Bishop to e1 King
37 and now Bishop back to be four we
have Kings to c7 and now comes a king to
e5 simply not allowing the White King
too much squares but of course you can't
do this forever
King to d7 now comes rush up to a3 we
have King to c6 and now comes King to d4
King to c7 King to c3 we have King to d7
and now kink the B for black is still
devising a way on how to how to approach
this we have King to e a king to d6 now
comes King capture son b3 but now it
comes with check King D 5 and now Bishop
back to be to King 36 we have Bishop to
f6
now comes King to c5 and now a king to
c3
King to d6 and now King to d4 we have
King to see a c6 and now finally Maxine
brings his rook into the game rook to d8
we have King to be 6 and now King to d5
King to c7 and now we have King deceased
King to c5 and now you can see that the
king and rook are cutting off the white
king from entering the game now you
either have to move your king for
example King to b7 and allow something
like butter to e5 which takes away even
more of your squares and there's really
not much you can do here you're you're
getting checkmated with whether you want
to or not so here Bishop to f7 was
played and now comes g5 a nice free move
for a fur magazine F captures on g6 and
now Rock the d6
we have Bishop to e8 better up to 8
Bishop to e5 now threatening some
discoveries King to b7 and now look to
b6 taking away even more squares for the
White King we have King to see it and
now comes King to d6 and it was in this
position I moved 76 that Alexandre
morosa which resigned the game so there
we have it I really I gave it a lot of
thought about the quote above the board
for this game but I wanted to have
something something that really shows
how that 26 move wasn't meant to be in
this tournament as it would probably
grant amorosa which a win in this 2009
bill chest first of all because Maxie
Marshall DeGraw won this tournament only
a half a point ahead of Alexander Monro
Zurich and I believe a vastly von Schuch
so this win for Alexander morosa which
would definitely clinch first place for
him but yeah what if you resign well now
there's really nothing to do here you
white has to make a move you can either
go Bishop to d7 and then you're just
getting King to e7 and now there's no
defense against the rook the g8
checkmate whatever you play you can even
bring your Queen into the game black
will simply ignore you and deliver
checkmate or if you're you know one of
those people that likes to make life
difficult for others then you can even
play something like pond to h8 Queen and
give up some material after Bishop to e5
force another capture but at least the
game will last longer but in the end
King to e7 is coming and
one more move is made then checkmate is
coming so yeah after King 36 like we
said Maxie marshal de Graaff won this
very nice game or Rosa which resigned
and Maxime like we said also won this
tournament so like I said a lot of you
have requested this game especially
especially mr. jolly one 996 so I do
hope you enjoyed it for tomorrow we've
we've prepared the Fischer series and
I'm very eager to get back to that also
I would ever I would like to take this
opportunity to wish a happy birthday to
mr. it American or I was contacted by
his significant other asking me if I
could you know do this do this honor for
him so it's always nice to wish someone
happy birthday so happy birthday to you
and I wish you I wish you have
celebrated at doing what you love most
so I would like to thank John John
Wensley Warren Gibson and Jonas
Torstensson
Kevin Strange and Carmen Mara's for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon most likely starting the Bobby
Fischer series thank you all and I'll
see you soon